there are people here Joy Behar wants to
be told what to do there is a there is a
portion of the population here that
wants systems of big government telling
them what to do they are uncomfortable
with their own personal decision making
they are uncomfortable with you making
your own decisions they're uncomfortable
with personal responsibility they are
uncomfortable with the values that built
this country and made it the land of the
free they are out to turn it around they
don't want America to be the land of the
free if they wanted that they wouldn't
have wanted you to have to get a
mandatory shot to walk into a restaurant
to eat a damn sandwich they don't want
that structure so when people say you
know there's a lot of my friend Jesse
Kelly on Twitter all the time is always
like the Communist the Communists and
when he first started saying this I was
like oh this guy's out of his mind now
I'm like the Communist the Communist
because it's real there are people here
who want to undermine what makes this
country great so it's some of it is
first world problems sure the lazy the
complacent and some of it is a
deliberate effort by some to wreck this
country that has to be gutted out like a
cancer